il ya mis un trouble de langage modéré à
sévère
le contact avec l'autre c'était
difficile je suis même un peu à part
parce que les autres enfants ne
comprenais pas il comprenait pas aussi
qu'est ce que william avait hélé par
faisant tout va bien s'intégrer pour en
avoir le coeur net christelle michaud se
rend à l'école espionner puis à l'heure
rester là toute la récréation observer
mon garçon comme allié t il reste à sin
semaines atteint ce isolés dès la
maternelle
william va souffrir pendant tout son
primaire
je commence à l'histoire
je me fais tu me dira d'aller regarder
le croquis arrivé j'ai eu ma capuche
bouleversement ouailles quand j'arrive à
à l'école j'ai fêté mon dieu il m'a vidé
mon sac
il me paye mon lunch et tous deux fait
bien brouilly partie la plus facile il
partit la première année où il était
triste
la deuxième année où lyon avait commencé
par quand même il y avait au grand ainsi
le petit x peuvent vraiment fort les
incidents d'intimidation vont se
multiplier et devenir plus violents
souvent sur le chemin de l'école
jso pris un gars qui a échappé ce
conseil ait brisé les i met your mother
qui commence à frapper totalement mais
j'ai pas fait exprès puis 17 mar froid
parce que j'ai pas vu il dit si tu pas
et peuvent avoir que les voir arriver le
coup
l'école est devenue un enfer avec ses
coûts
ces insultes et menaces qu'ils endurent
en silence
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en novembre 2011 le québec est secoué
par le suicide d'une adolescente de 15
ans marjorie raymond son geste est
attribué en partie à l'intimidation qui
subissait à l'école ce drame le
gouvernement réagit quelques mois plus
tard il adopte rapidement une loi qui
oblige les écoles à s'occuper de la
violence et de l'intimidation une grande
grande pression politique pour sortir la
loi et ils ont produit une loi en petit
qui est moi on s'entend très bien faible
perfectible mais qui est quand même très
bien faible ça a commencé environ deux
mois une gamme de gants créé des faux
profils qui ont commencé à mécary sur
facebook depuis les campagnes de
sensibilisation se sont succédé le plus
fort c'est de faire comme si j'avais
rien vu futur parler
parce qu'on sent qu'on semble fort que
l'intimidation
huit ans plus tard comment mesurer
l'efficacité de la loi nous cognon à
plusieurs portes pour filmer dans une
école secondaire cinq commissions
scolaires refuse le sujet est délicat et
le milieu scolaire est un univers
hermétique qui se méfie des journalismes
finalement direction saint jérôme une
petite école secondaire de 725 élèves
l'école saint stanislas accepte de nous
recevoir pendant une semaine
seule condition préserver l'anonymat des
élèves
[Musique]
lundi matin 8 heures l'école s'anime le
directeur des enseignants et des membres
du personnel de soutien organise la
semaine qui commence les cellulaires
sont interdits dupiol je le veux qu'il
soit permis au musée une à moi je crois
que nos bleus car s'est implanté l'école
ce qu'elle disait c'est que c'était
favoriser les relations sociales entre
les élèves pour l'immersion et croient
ils sont maintenant moi
[Musique]
une vervins normand charrette accueilli
les élèves
nous on accueille les élèves le matin et
nous les posons un nas une surveillance
les ardennais on a su novaliance le
sauver qu'est-ce qu'on surveille on
ferait il avions le bon fonctionnement
nos élèves ont observé les comportements
de nos élèves si nos élèves font des
inondations ces douze élèves manquent de
respect le langage nos élèves si nos
élèves quittent le territoire colas nous
élèvent et consomment sur le territoire
scolaire
sinon les élèves revient de ce dîner en
état de consommation on surveille tout
tout tout au tout
c'est faux cul sur l'intimidation et on
veut savoir la vie parce qu'on sent en
tant que c'est pas ces incendies cela ce
type d'intimidation
non mon charrette s'occupe des élèves du
secondaire 1 et 2 ceux ci soient vos
gros ce soir ses proches a cependant
stand animal qui s'occupe secondaire 5 a
déjà une jeune dans son bureau tout est
rattrapable
tous les deux sont techniciens en
éducation spécialisée
on les appelle les ts
il ne reste pas deux minutes en place
ils observent écoutent interviennent
deux fois deux jours on a jeté dans
l'eau avec ma femme et qu'elle vient
ainsi conforter les jeunes écoutent et
les jeunes c'est tout qu'est ce qui est
en dehors des périodes de classe mais
qu'est-ce qui pendant la ronde des foies
la 6e du manque de respect classement de
lesparre l'adulte les communications
perd 1 on travaille là dessus
les écoles ont maintenant l'obligation
légale de prendre des mesures pour
lutter contre l'intimidation mais
chacune est libre d'attaquer le problème
comme elle veut du tout les situations
d'intimidation qui nous sont rapportés
soit aux indiens ou une zone de
l'encadrement
et puis aux cellules il doit avoir un
conte de fées là oui il y en a des six
nations dont la situation de yara
s'était pas fait avant-hier quand je
retourne à la maison pour nous
l'intimidation c'est
s'ils enregistrent une fois on
intervient on n'attend pas la récurrence
pour intervenir l'intimidation on
n'attend pas la gratuité le cancer break
tout seul on intervient rapidement avec
mon intervient pour un geste qu'on a vu
dans le corridor ont été remis pour une
parole qu'on a entendu on intervient
pour quelque chose qui s'est passé à
l'autobus leurs secrets dans la rapidité
d'intervention identifier la victime est
plus complexe qu'avant je pense que
toute personne peut être pourrait être
victime d'intimidation je pense que
l'intimidateur va toujours chercher les
personnes fragiles ces deux seuls 20 des
élèves qui ont pas tendance à aller
chercher de l'aide auprès des délais de
l'adulte des élèves qui ont de la
difficulté au niveau social des élèves
qui ont un manque d'habileté au niveau
social
[Musique]
à l'école william rasent les murs des
casiers il n'a pas de classe où se
cacher il vit constamment dans la peur
du moment où son bourreau va surgir
exploser à chaque son chaque soir car
messi était hystérique
ils pleuraient criaient et frapper non
et vous ne comprenez pas personne ne
comprend et plein effort chez tout le
temps on sait pas pourquoi bronze du
bain pourtant failli tout le monde et
c'est tout le monde puis quand vous
vivez en parler et d'isaac à veyrier mes
choix
c'est le psychologue qui a dit votre
fils et vit quelque chose c'est selon je
me sens très triste
j'avais je pleurais je pleurais n'ai pas
envie d'aller à l'école non ça
william s'occuper de satisfaire quand il
revenait à la maison pour dîner ou le
soir qui ma fille a marché toujours au
loin
après son nul pourquoi qu elle seule
était toujours loin de son frère qui l'a
dit si tu avais une seule nature et je
vais te manger pas toi je voulais pas
qu'ils fassent et qu'ils sont
[Musique]
williams devient colérique il se fait
punir et il est souvent isolés au local
de retrait en quelques mois il est
devenu un élève avec des problèmes de
comportement
ce que vous décrivez là c'est un cas
c'est pas ces parcours extrêmement rares
en france à bourine de l'université de
montréal étudie les problèmes de
violence en milieu scolaire
c'est un club qui peut se produire quand
même assez régulièrement chez les
victimes d'intimidations ou s'ils sont
de plus en plus aux livres subissent de
plus en plus de pression d'anxiété de
peur d'incompréhension
ben ils vont développer ils vont devient
extrêmement réactif play vont développer
de la cola
[Musique]
l'intimidation ccpo c'est pas un
événement qui arrive soudainement des
conflits d'enfants c'est un conflit
spontanée qui va se produit qu'on va
régler l'intimidation c'est comme la
goutte d'eau se comme le supplice de la
goutte d'eau jusqu'au sud s'est toujours
frappé à même place tout le temps
véronique turcotte nous raconte ce que
sa fille a vécu en 4e année du primaire
ils étaient cinq jeunes sur son dos je
me suis assise avec ma fille j'ai dit
l'autre mon dieu qu'est-ce qui te montre
la gueule chacun
quand j'ai tout noté
[Musique]
avec un essentiellement c'est du
dénigrement des bousculades
c'était des agressions physiques se
dénonce de taille
taille tout faire dire de se fermer sa
gueule de ta journée langue c'est d'eux
qu'il fallait qu'elles obéissent fait le
cafard ce qu'est ce qu'elle est la
petite l'autre voulez qu'elle fasse
sinon elle se faisait dénigrer se
fermaient à l'école
ostracisé par les autres se fermaient de
côté ce verdict était probable tout
autre franco c'était en 2011 avant la
loi sur l'intimidation est là depuis
poursuivi devant les tribunaux
la commission scolaire la directrice et
deux enseignantes et les accuse de ne
pas avoir protégé sa fille elle n'avait
pas besoin d'être là d'un moment j'ai
besoin d'elle même à [ __ ] je sais plus
quoi faire
parce que au début tout ça ça s'amplifie
j'ai besoin d'un homme je suis plus quoi
faire notre mandat ton professeur de t&d
wima veut rien savoir qu est ce qu a dit
indice toi aussi tu as fait des enfants
tout aussi tendue des enfants c'est tout
à sa gamme dit elle avait dit tu es à
ses gammes pour régler des affaires tout
seul ceci ce qu'elle lui avait dit sa
fille se plaignait quotidiennement du
harcèlement de certains élèves
ma fille s'est retrouvé pendant les deux
écuries assise au centre de ses trois
enfants lors à se faire lancer des
poches de deux jeux de poches de sang
bleu puis des élastiques et jouer à la
visée était dans le sens qui fait
clairement donné à changer de place à
s'en aller dans l'autre classe pour
qu'ils arrêtent puis l'a poursuivie
jusque là bord je suis allé voir sur le
sur facebook pour savoir que ce qui se
passait c'est là que j'ai vu qu'il y
avait six enfants guérilla de ma fille
sur une période d'une semaine
6la lors je ne sais pas si vous savez
hélas le cas tu te rends compte y en a
six qui restent un enfant ont annoncé
lundi qu'ils arrêtent de lettres de
princesses de que c'est pas ton ami puis
que c'est le seul habit c'est la moins
bonne ça vous et chacun
ça en fait monsieur gelé tout le temps a
dit non
[Musique]
/ je m'assois 6 un salon que j'ai pleuré
courriels appels visite à l'école elle
revient à la charge
après chaque incident trop souvent au
goût du personnel qui lui demande de ne
plus mettre les pieds à l'école me suis
dit bon le fauchage quelque chose plus
j'en ai entendu parler qu'il y avait des
policiers qu'avec une formation pour
intervenir en milieu scolaire fait que
j'ai appelé les secours
la famille habite à saint paul
d'abbotsford en montérégie qui est
desservi par la sûreté du québec
la policière responsable de la
prévention dans les écoles la rassure
demandé à la directrice de rencontrer
ces enfants l'eau puis leur dire mon
dieu qu'est-ce qu'ils vont se procurer
car dans la foule à l'école la
directrice a dit non
rentrent pas dans mon école tenant
compte du confort de mon école
ce matin présence policière à l'école
saint stanislas à saint-girons et doit
se passer quelque chose de grave
pourtant personne ne semble s'en étonner
ça brison du pool image en fond de la
police qui sert kafana dépression depuis
l'adoption de la loi en 2012
chaque école doit avoir une entente avec
le service de police de sa communauté
là jean gabriel pageau se rend tous les
jours dans trois écoles secondaires de
saint jérôme
pour créer un lien de confiance et on
leur donne des enseignements sur ce que
c'est l'intimidation à partir du primat
moi je pense qu'on voit une super belle
évolution de où est-ce qu'on était à 20
puisqu'on en est maintenant
les adolescents sont beaucoup plus haut
au fait de ce que c'est l'intimidation
beaucoup plus haut fait aussi de
l'aspect qu'on ne doit pas cautionner ce
fut la jeune maman
aujourd'hui il rencontre des élèves de
secondaire 1 pour leur parler de
pornographie juvénile plus
particulièrement de sextos ce qui passe
à des comptes de réseaux sociaux
un phénomène en émergence chez des
adolescents qui peut mener à de
l'intimidation
à québec la crise des sextos a ébranlé
le séminaire des pères maristes il ya
deux ans
cinq élèves secondaire ont plaidé
coupables à des accusations liées à la
pornographie juvénile
ça dépasse nous limitent à l'école et
c'est le point que les pilotes tous les
années 90
comme dans d'autres écoles c'est arrivé
aussi à saint stanislas
et ça commence bien souvent en seconde
erreur comme ça ça se parle les écoles
des jeunes qui demande d'envoyer des
photos de nudité et qu'il ya de la
pression sociale pour casser ces jeunes
filles l'eau ce jeune garçon leur envoie
des photos nues ch'ti et
finissent pas de l'envoyer en bikini
pilot kaka s'est fait envoyer en bikini
en ce moment à leur ont dit ok si suma
n'envoie pas une laissée nue je monte
l'autre qui sera envoyée enregistre in
l'agent majou donne l'exemple de martin
et martine
un couple qui s'échangent volontairement
des photos intimes
le fait que martin puis martin ils se
prennent en photo avec leur téléphone
c'est là ils font ce qu'on appelle la
production de pornographie juvénile fait
que c'est une première infraction qui
pourrait mener à des accusations
criminelles
en sus de sa distribution on le fait
d'envoyer la photo il faut la
distribution de pornographie juvénile
mais finalement la possession avec
martin il garde la photo martin dans son
téléphone ils se trouvaient est en panne
en possession de pornographie juvénile
fait même si on fait ce constat de façon
constante et que personne n'est au
courant de soupe qui aucune conséquence
le simple fait qu'ils aient échangé une
seule photo martin martin y ont commis
trois infractions les trs l'enfant qui
traitent ces informations le camp qui
voit qu'il ya quelque chose qui va
toucher le fond le cadre légal le cadre
du monde du policier du 14 le yvon mme
solis type c'est le aux joueurs greffés
comme si jamais vous avez des questions
ou des mois ça me fait vraiment plaisir
que ce soit par rapport à ceux où par
rapport à n'importe quoi d'autre
quand vous croisez dans l'école
n'hésitez pas
[Musique]
la troisième année j'essaie de faire mon
marché changent d'école change des jeux
peut changer d'école je veux changer
quand j'ai subi
j'ai fait des petites histoires plus de
plaistow clech pleurer à chaque fois il
ya été voir un psychologue ou liam parce
que à côté tu es belle 3 enragé conclave
y avait peu d'espoir pour williams en
effet il y avait un psychologue et c'est
le travail du psychologue qui est dit
c'est william hill fausse part nous on
peut pas deviner ce que tu vis à l'heure
du coucher crise thèse ce soit aux côtés
de son fils elle attend espère une
confidence la première fois 7 à dans son
lit il pleurait et criait c'est pour ce
que je vis je sais que tu vas pas bien
mais c'est quoi ces lots qui dit elle a
tout les soirs je me fait tabasser je me
fais donne des coups de pieds vite mon
sac d'école qui est a tout déchiré son
sac la danse est arrachée c'est l'oeuvre
à mâcon de vue que ce testeur du crabe
lost heroes ce club c'est plus tolérable
les devs pas en repos parce que c'est
par là l'école sont encore plus sur mon
dos christelle et françois ne l'écoutent
pas et fonce vers l'école qui semble
être au courant il savait des situations
dit oui aussi qu'il se fait traiter des
ados dead des noms mais on gère la
situation mais je me disais ok ça ça
vaut tu fais confiance aux choix de
faire confiance des polos à l'écouté les
parents se font promettre par le
personnel de l'école qu'ils auront
l'intimidateur à l'oeil qui lui sera
interdit d'approcher ou diane que les
professeurs de 3,10 euros ont reculé
mais ils ont dû rencontrer
oui mais il y aurait en fait eu six
associés aux papiers mais ces syriens
quoi aussi et de contrat tu fais un pas
encore mais l'hôtesse lui l'école et non
il me fait encore mal et iront en classe
avant une chance une shop in shop in
shop ce jour là il faut qu'on voit un
faux et il faut qu'ils voient la
situation des preuves
christelle et françois n'ont pas aucun
témoin ne dénonce il n'y a pas de
caméras de surveillance à l'école
pourtant où il ya mme porte des
ecchymoses sur le dos et sa détresse est
plus que palpable
saint-stanislas la présence de caméras
dans les corridors et parfois
révélatrice on m'a dit ça s'est passé
12h35 car quand on a des situations de
même que
quand deux versions le mot différentes
on essaie de se faire une idée de ce qui
s'est passé de celle la main et ensuite
on va les confronter isolé avec la
situation sommes pas là elle explique
c'est soit ça
non non moi je le vois là ce cette
annexe i de la jeune personne n'a rien
de moins six touches six souches ce
n'est pas volontaire
c'est évident avec moi je vois les lois
l'aja mais voilà quand même les
sensibiliser parce qu'il ya eu un manque
de respect cette jeune loup est une
autre manque de l'espéranto envers l'eau
quoi c'est que ça passe à côté
les sultans port sans compter qu'ils ont
parfois d'intimidation tout de suite
c'est du manque de respect on fera une
intervention va les former les parents
janata circulent mais dans l'héritage
est assise au local de l'élever je vois
la rencontre et puis je vais faire une
mise en garde si je vous dis qu'elle
n'est pas que ce que j'ai vu puisque ce
que je suis devenu julie brière est
enseignante depuis 15 ans à chaque début
d'année
elle invite ses élèves a dénoncé s'ils
subissent de l'intimidation
son approche porte fruit
murat de frank rich a été mené est dans
le coup de chance avec les communautés
partout noté légitimité plus apprécié et
pitt six ans qui incarne parce que moi
j'ai pas marqué est-ce que ça se fait
dans les cordes par exemple quoi j'ai
mal j'ai vu un seul but montrer c'est
important que tu en parles je constate
qu'elle en est pas là madame marquis
passes contre ux à bercy où il y est je
ne sois bien je suis enseignante mais je
portais es jeux comme psychologue donc
souvent je vais demander de l'aide pour
savoir quoi faire on implique aussi les
parents si jeune et d'encore évidemment
mais c'est vraiment je trouve que
l'école ici j'en ai connu quelques-unes
mais l'école si vraiment l'encadrement
est à son top top top oui je présenterai
pour marquer du cnpc dans les saisies
des mémos est un outil informatique met
sur pied par la commission scolaire de
la rive-nord un système de messagerie où
tout est inscrit devoir non fait
absentéisme gestes d'intimidation manque
de respect du trace écrite qui
permettent de faire le suivi des élèves
l'an dernier 6100 mes mots ont été
rédigées à l'école saint stanislas
on est un jeune élève ans prévient son
tuteur le tuteur prévient d autres
enseignants dans la même journée
l'information circuler facilement tout
le monde est au courant
la direction et les enseignants sont
aussi très préoccupés depuis quelques
années par le nombre croissant d'élèves
qui souffrent d'anxiété chez sonia
d'univers social histoire géographie en
scène éducation financière puis je me
retrouve à gérer des crises de panique
d'angoua ddd même des problèmes
psychologiques
sébastien la rente a pris l'habitude
d'aller marcher avec ses élèves au début
des classes il leur enseigne également
la méditation
il y en a plusieurs qui vivent des
choses dramatiques cette année on a eu à
faire des références à des instances
sociales la fête l'hôpital psychiatrique
gérer des choses de crise des paniques
intense ou des troubles de personnalité
il ya beaucoup de problèmes dans goise
l'anxiété présente cette semaine avec
l'examen de chemins secondaires 5 puis
j'ai croisé trois jeunes emploi de
performance les troubles anxieux ils
s'ajoutent à l'intimidation qui n'a pas
disparu
l'école saint stanislas a recensé 42
actes de violence dont neuf cas
d'intimidation l'an dernier le principal
obstacle reste la dénonciation est ce
que disait de lait sans appel ce n'est
chez les élèves par le speech et parce
qu'ils ont la pression des pairs pour
pas dénoncer les situations qui sont
victimes les gens sont très réticents à
confier des adultes
la psychologue debra peppler étudie
l'agression et l'intimidation durant
l'enfance depuis plus de 30 ans elle
vient de remporter le prix du gouverneur
général pour l'ensemble de son travail
selon moi ils ne font pas confiance aux
adultes pour gérer le problème de façon
positive
c'est le système échoue on ne met pas
assez l'accent sur la sécurité des
enfants
nous n'avons pas suffisamment de
stratégie pour le protéger de ketchup
safe
je ne pourrai jamais lui parler à lisa
dit pas ce que je fais plus confiance et
c'est tout
non ben j'ai asseyé d'en parler à toulon
mais pur écouté personne tu écoutais
n'ont personne à qui tu en a parlé
ats à ma prof à mes amis personne n'y
croyait williams est alors en 4e année
la situation ne semble pas s'améliorer
et ses parents s'impatiente d'appeler
l'école
le teddy le jab la police si vous prenez
pas les choses en main mouleres l'est
pas c'est à brosser mais la surface et
qui ont pris l'enfant qu'intime veolia
l'ont bien en phase de william qui ont
dit ils les ont confrontés les deux
parce que tu as fait ça ou les amis du
bénin mais le scellage et 10 mètres fait
ça pour de vrai de même l'intimidateur
devant médecine aux interventions qu'on
fait mais timide à temps et peut
intéresser la régler son problème
ils tirent des avantages il ya plus de
monde qui le regardent qu'il encourage
c'est le kent où c'est la queen de la
place il ya du pouvoir belle idée où
sont ses avantages a été la victime est
terrorisée donc on va pas mettre de
l'agresseur on va pas faire des
activités en mettant les agresseurs et
les victimes un homme ça s'est fortement
déconseillé
même s'il a finalement dénoncé la
situation sont l'intimidateur s'acharne
williams s'enfonce dans la dépression
pensée d'amour et parce que j'en avais
marre d'être sérieux je priais je priais
je priais pour pour mourir parce que
j'en ai jamais vraiment puissesseau
j'épuré ajouté
on
c'était clair que ça semblait wallon
doigts de la catastrophe
c'était si c'était tout écrit travail et
est restée y est encore là et d'écoles
colérique
à la fin il voulait s'enlever la vie ça
passe t on est rendus où il était il ya
des gens qui avaient remarqué très
longtemps et une bonne partie de leur
vie parce que la situation a pas trouvé
d'issue favorable
sacré ce qu'on appelle une espèce de
choc traumatique nommé y en a un certain
nombre qui vivent un tel sentiment
solitude de rejet de faible estime de
soi de culpabilité que dans certains cas
ça peut se rendre jusqu'au suicide
selon le bureau du coroner du québec six
jeunes se sont enlevé la vie depuis 2012
en partie à cause de l'intimidation
qu'il subissait à l'école margerie
raymond kim pettersen alexandre lemay
bélanger williams en deux
simon dufour samuel patrice nous avons
appris au cours des 10 ou 15 dernières
années que les blessures sont beaucoup
plus profonds comme moins un enfant de
10 ans qui se réveille avec la crainte
d'être à nouveau victimes et forcément
présents sur pour l'école terrifiée
parce que tout moment son bourreau peut
surgir pour l'heure seuls et isolés et
on commence à mesurer combien musulman
est néfaste au développement cndd n 6 a
highly prouve profonde tristesse parce
qu'il n'y a personne avec qui jouer
personne avec hidden chez il a le
sentiment d'être une personne sans
valeur d'être en quelque sorte non
encore infectés
[Musique]
toute la petite enfance qui est détruite
par le rejet toutes les atteintes à la
réputation tout la diffamation
mais j'allais sauvée du suicide c'est ça
[Musique]
la loi contre l'intimidation a été
adopté sans mécanisme pour mesurer son
efficacité
les écoles ne sont pas obligées de
répertorier tous les incidents mais
elles sont mieux outillés qu'avant non
papa la balle est aujourd'hui avec ça
ah bon quelque 220 kw et trois français
je pense aux devoirs dans ce titre le
fait que je vais devoir
je m'explique à l'assaut si quelque
chose on allongera ensemble
à saint stanislas on met sur une
intervention rapide sont bousculés la
victime c'est insidieux l'intimidation
donc faut toujours revenir à la charge
avec les personnes qui étaient intimidés
pour voir est ce que c'est encore et
qu'est-ce que se passe quelque chose de
correct tout ça parce que c'est tendance
à revenir tout et on met des moyens
ensuite proposé sur le produisent pour
boxer reviennent
dernièrement j'ai changé les lèvres de
tous vu cela j'avais la chance de
pouvoir trouver un autre lieu sa célèbre
l'eau et imitateur qu'il est timide et
il faut essayer de pas changer son train
train quotidien
ok les victimes n'ont pas changé son
terrain comme si cette motion la
personne qui faisait d'intimidation
on ne trouve on est chanceux il y avait
un autre but un autobus qui possédant
même dans l'entourage la jeune à la à
marcher plus loin on peut faire plus de
distance belle collaboration des parents
on change on change l'autobus celle-là
et l'eau y eut des conséquences qui sont
venus avec ça ja je la voyais jupille
commence à bord d'un autobus
ouahmed shoji pas d'amis à qui je sais
c'est ça c'est ça ta conséquences
nationales
tous les cas ne se règle pas par un
changement d'autobus
parfois la suspension devient la
solution et nous on court pas les
subventions externe c'est pas une
conséquence et du suspense de la maison
nous ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on a un
local de les tripler nos élèves sont
suspendus le cadre de la dre et
deux jours où ça parlait plus longue
sauf si l'élève ne veut pas que la barre
est toujours aux dalles l île et pendant
le collaboration pour développer plus
suspendre l'intimidateur à la maison
n'est pas la solution
lorsqu'on les renvoient à la maison ils
sont dégagés de toute responsabilité à
l'école ils peuvent jouer aux jeux vidéo
traîner dans les rues
ce n'est pas la solution je crois qu'il
faut voir l'intimidation comme un
problème de développement plutôt que de
discipline on doit donc se demander
qu'est ce que cet enfant n'a pas
développé qu'il devrait développer et
que celles développées qui le desservira
dans l'avenir
quel bilan peut-on faire huit ans après
l'adoption de la loi depuis 2013 la
chaire de recherche bien-être à l'école
et prévention de la violence de
l'université laval mène des sondages
auprès de trente mille élèves parents et
membres du personnel scolaire
le gouvernement s'appuie sur ces
sondages pour dire qu'il ya certaines
améliorations
reste que 15 % des élèves du primaire et
du secondaire subissent encore des
comportements violents à répétition au
moins trois fois par mois 15 % ce sont
160 mille enfants ils sont la priorité
pour françois bourret fois-ci
d'identifier les enfants qui le sont
fictives pour le dénoncer pour les
inciter à demander de l'aide elle
dénoncé ou à leurs amis ou aux témoins
passifs qui sont pas nécessairement leur
année de dénoncer ces actes
[Musique]
les écoles n'ont pas à répertorier les
cas d'intimidation mais elles doivent
rapporter aux commissions scolaires les
plaines faite par les parents en 2010
est le protecteur du citoyen à critiquer
le système de plaintes en milieu
scolaire les délais sont trop longs
le protecteur de l'élève ne peut pouvoir
de recommandation
et surtout il est inaccessible les
parents doivent s'armer de patience
d'abord ils se plaignent un enseignant
puis au bureau de la direction d'école
se sont satisfaits de l'intervention
d'école le dossier est réglé sinon il
porte plainte au responsable de l'examen
des plaintes à la commission scolaire
si ça ne va toujours pas le parcours du
combattant se poursuit jusqu'au conseil
des commissaires
le dossier n'est toujours pas réglée 5e
étape
l'ultime palier ce n'est qu'à ce moment
c'est en ou encore l'énergie que les
parents ont le droit de s'adresser pour
protecteur de l'élève
[Musique]
ce que c'était facile de se rendre
jusqu'aux protecteur de l'élève non non
et et quoi pourquoi choisir un nom il
faut que tu écris tous les noms tous les
arts les dates
c'est une procédure ses rangs le manque
sera aussi loin parce que c'est
extrêmement long et ça te demande
beaucoup d'énergie à et ses trésors
ouais parce que si tu fais une erreur by
rhj est complète
[Musique]
christelle et françois n'en veulent pas
vraiment aux membres du personnel de
l'école qui sont débordées distille mais
ils se sont battus pour que william
change d'école une école qui répondrait
mieux à ses besoins selon hu
nous avons épluché les rapports des
protecteurs de l'élève des 72
commissions scolaires pour savoir
combien de plaintes liées à de
l'intimidation s'étaient rendus jusqu'à
eux
au total ils ont retenu 580 une plainte
de ce nombre 42 concerne un acte de
violence ou d'intimidation en 2018 ce
qui représente 7 % des plaintes analysés
par les protecteurs de l'élève
insatisfaite du traitement de sa plainte
véronique turcotte a porté l affaire
devant les tribunaux
dans son jugement rendu le 1er octobre
dernier le tribunal est d'avis que le
personnel scolaire à traiter à la légère
des plaines de la jeune fille
il a pratiqué un aveuglement volontaire
et a eu peu d'empathie envers elle et
ses parents
les événements se sont passés avant
l'adoption de la loi sur l'intimidation
mais la nécessité de protéger cet enfant
vulnérable est une question de gros bon
sens et de sensibilité note la juge
c'est la première fois au québec qu'une
commission scolaire des enseignantes et
une directrice sont tenus
personnellement responsables dans un cas
d'intimidation la cour les condamnait
des dommages moraux et punitifs qui est
évalué à 68 mille dollars
je ne pense pas que ça fasse peur un tel
jugement fasse peur aux enseignants ça
fasse sa voix plutôt faire réfléchir sur
pour mais qu'est ce qu'on doit faire
pour mettre les choses en place
puis l'auto je termine razza il ya
pleinement qui font ce qu'ils ont à
faire
fait que ces gens là disent moi j'ai
rien à me reprocher mais ce peut être
qu'il t'a pas conscient de la gravité de
ce genre de situation là puis la
nécessité d'intervenir sa volée fait
réfléchir les commissions scolaires a
refusé notre demande d'entrevue elle et
le personnel de l'école soutiennent
qu'ils n'ont commis aucune faute et qui
n'ont pas voulu nuire à sept enfants il
en appel de ce jugement qui représente
un dangereux précédent
selon lui
la fille de véronique turcotte a dû
changer d'école en 5e année
aujourd'hui elle est au cégep et elle va
beaucoup mieux pour williams
c'est plus compliqué
et il ya un traumatisme office même
l'école lundi
il travaille il ya un traumatisme office
de sculptures on voit on le sent quand
même plus dans sa chambre c'est pourquoi
il faut bien les besoins dette avec
dumont ya besoin de sens et qu'on lots
ça sent le besoin de l'emporter
il a changé d'école en septembre dernier
où il ya me fréquentent une école de
soutien émotif pour enfants avec
troubles de comportement mais il n'y est
pas heureux
puis il m'avait dit que fo j'aille dans
l'école de fou récolte serieys qui
pigent des bureaux détruits demande
nicole de fou mais c'est le fric idol
que nous ferons la besogne
c'est pas vraiment mon principal
courtier
le protecteur de l'élève refuse de
référé williams à l'école choisie par
les parents déclarant qu'ils ont les
ressources nécessaires pour lui et
n'allez pas en forêt en théorie il est
difficile de trouver des stratégies elle
est subie dation parce que nous avons
différentes formes d'intimidation autour
de nous au quotidien ça change mais
lentement parce que les hommes ont eu le
pouvoir sur les femmes n a pas ce que
les adultes pour le pouvoir sur les
enfants selon moi il est donc nécessaire
de parler de pouvoir dans des écoles de
notre façon de l'utiliser et de ce qu'on
ressent lorsque quelqu'un utilise ce
pouvoir de façon négative sur le web and
o
les élèves doivent apprendre à évoluer
les rapports de force
on n'y est pas encore mais les choses
évoluent
[Musique]
voir
si la loi a contribué à améliorer la
situation
il devient urgent d'apprendre aux jeunes
à gérer leurs émotions des experts que
nous avons consultés suggère de
l'inclure dans le nouveau cours
d'éthique et culture religieuse parfait
trois éléments gérer ses émotions ça
s'apprend tout comme on apprend le
français et les mathématiques
[Musique]
je